bitcoin once thought to be an asset
similar to gold however during russia's
invasion of ukraine we've seen these two
assets take two very different paths
joining us right now is anthony popliano
pomp investments founder and partner
anthony good morning to you
we're all just trying to make sense of
of what bitcoin is supposed to be we've
been told it's current a currency we've
been told it's digital gold
some people think it's a religion
uh some people think it's a nasdaq stock
what do you think it really is
yeah well thanks again for having me
look i think that ultimately uh bitcoin
sources different things different
people you know if you look at money in
general money is a religion whether it's
fiat currency uh whether it's bitcoin
etc to put confidence in the item that
you're willing to exchange for goods or
services so i think that that's true
across a lot of different assets but
when you start to look at kind of
ukraine and russia situation what's
fascinating to me is on the news of the
actual invasion uh gold moved upwards
slightly and bitcoin actually went down
a couple of percent but since about 5 30
uh on thursday morning what we've seen
is bitcoin's up 10 and gold's actually
down about half a percent and so what i
think is we got to be careful of is not
judging the performance of these assets
based on a couple of hours
but i do think that the prevailing
narrative of bitcoin being that digital
gold being a censorship resistant
technology especially when we see
sanctions not only the united states to
russia but we see china sanctioning
raytheon and lockheed or we see canada
sanctioning some of their own citizens i
think this is going to become a bigger
and bigger narrative and bitcoin is
going to continue to serve as one of the
solutions uh as the world kind of wakes
up to the fact that financial censorship
is uh people
and look you know you know my job is to
be the professional skeptic and and
plays delaware's advocate here but if we
lay we're laying a gold uh chart over a
bitcoin chart what we should do is lay a
nasdaq chart over a bitcoin chart
because as bitcoin went up even in the
past day you saw the markets also
returned so doesn't it just suggest here
we have a remarkably speculative asset
yeah i think that you've got to look at
a couple of different things so there's
definitely two different types of
holders of bitcoin uh pre maybe end of
2020 it was definitely mostly retail and
they treat bitcoin as a reserve asset
starting in the end of 2020 when we saw
paul tudor jones stanley druckenmiller a
lot of institutions start to come in
those folks look at bitcoin as the
riskiest asset in their portfolio and so
whenever we go to a risk-off environment
they're going to sell the asset those
retail investors though when you look at
the on-chain metrics continue to just
dollar cost average and hold the asset
so still a pretty illiquid asset the
other component of this i think is
really important we look at price over
the last three or four months is that at
the end of 2021 uh bitcoin was up 65 a
lot of the crypto market was up 10 15 20
x and so a lot of fund managers were
just taking profits they end up booking
those profits to take their fee
and so i think that kind of going into
tax season you'll see some selling for
taxes etc and then we'll kind of be off
to the races again but i wouldn't read
too much into the last three or four
months of price movement just given that
it had gone up so much compared to other
assets like the stock market
etc hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time